drunk ass audience look at this
yo hurry up
someone else in the corner look at this
like I don't know because the
reason y'all going to the bathroom I
just don't know what it is it's weird
right I'm not the only person noticing
another coming in this crazy
what the is wrong with you people
look at this what is this what's
going on y'all yeah I'm the only one
noticing how much I gotta pee that's my
whole thing I gotta pee every 90 minutes
is crazy
if I gotta do a second intermission just
y'all could pee what the hell is
happening
from now on it's gonna it's gonna be
Elementary School give me the
key to the bathroom y'all want it y'all
gonna ask permission
I'm Gonna Keep y'all here for four hours
I had enough
I'm getting angry at you Vancouver